a growing number of doctors and nurses
say the pandemic is stretching our
healthcare system to the brink of
disaster
our national correspondent Jericka
Duncan has talked to health care workers
on the frontlines Jericka one doctor
says he was actually fired for speaking
up was like a war zone with limited
resources
forty-year-old doctor arabia Mallette is
an emergency physician at two hospitals
serving low-income communities in New
York City
she says she took this video inside ver
clins Brookdale University Hospital
Medical Center a pediatric ER has been
turned into a makeshift isolation room
using plastic tape from the ceiling to
the floor to help protect nurses and
doctors from Kovac 19 we're fighting for
your lives but we also fighting for our
lives too we are also scared some are so
scared and so frustrated they have taken
to social media to vent dr. Ming Lin is
an ER doctor who worked for a hospital
outside of Seattle through a contractor
he says he was fired after sharing his
concerns about health care workers
safety on Facebook his employer
physician contractor team health said in
a statement that it has not terminated
dr. Lin a lot of us are intimidated from
talking a lot of us you know choose to
remain anonymous it's because our voice
is suppressed everywhere you turn the
emotional toll this pandemic is taking
on medical professionals is palpable
diana lake is an ER doctor in maryland
she's taking extreme measures to protect
her family I've cried many days I
haven't seen my children in 13 days
they're with my ex-husband and basically
we're concerned for having them around
me because I don't know what I'm
bringing home I reached out to my
therapist I said I need you again
because this is hard this is tough I
don't want to carry this burden on me so
I'm not ashamed of that because this is
a part of mental health I'm no different
from the next person
and at the end there you just heard from
dr. Arabia Mallette now just to give you
perspective about how real this is for
some of these doctors dr. Millette said
several several people in her family
have contracted Kovan 19 including her
mother who's a nurse she says her mom
was in the hospital for two weeks
thankfully she's now at home recovering
but this is what these nurses and these
doctors are dealing with as they said
not just trying to save the people who
come in there's lives but also knowing
that they too could be infected and are
highly likely to be infected and then
hearing that their loved ones are being
infected all while this pandemic is
happening in real time
yeah drinka it's important to keep in
mind it's the very definition of courage
and we thank all those on the frontlines
thank you very much to Rica